i intend to step down as leader of the
democratic unionist party on the 28th of
may
and as the first minister of northern
ireland at the end of june
it is important the announcement for
marlene foster will have surprised few
people
such was the pressure she's been under
from her democratic unionist party
but it does open a new unpredictable
chapter in northern ireland politics
it has been the privilege of my life to
serve the people of northern ireland as
their first minister and of course
to represent my home constituency of
framana and south tyrone
arlene foster took over as leader of the
democratic unionist party from peter
robinson in december 2015.
it made her the first woman to lead the
pro-british party
and to serve as northern ireland's first
minister less than a year later
officials said serious systemic failings
over a scrapped renewable energy scheme
would hit the budget available to the
stormont assembly
arlene foster's opponents demanded she
resign when she refused the deputy first
minister martin mcguinness
from the republican shin fame party quit
bringing down the power sharing
executive
which would stay out of action for three
years
during that period the uk under prime
minister theresa may
was negotiating its brexit divorce deal
with the european union
foster and her party strongly backed
boris johnson the then foreign secretary
when he promised to fight any attempt to
impose a sea border
but certainly this gives us a border in
the irish sea in terms of
that in terms of customs by rejecting
the may deal
the dup smoothed johnson's path to
downing street
but the brexit deal or withdrawal
agreement that prime minister johnson
eventually signed
effectively created a border in the
irish sea making northern ireland
subjects to different rules from
mainland britain
and in recent months northern ireland's
been hit by rioting
it's been partly attributed to unionist
concerns about the province's position
in the uk
being weakened many dup members have
been angry that foster hasn't denounced
the northern ireland protocol which
imposes checks on goods coming from
britain
more forcefully the fallout from brexit
is likely to be one of the toughest
challenges for her successor too
nadine barber al jazeera